I'm happy to introduce Amy Stefanovic
from access now
psychotic cruel vicious these are words
that were used to describe Nicodemo
Scarfo who was the one time boss of the
Philadelphia crime family and my talk
today begins where nicodemos story ends
which is at the trial that led to the
current life sentence he's serving in
the atlanta federal penitentiaries
Scarfo ended up with this life sentence
because he went to trial and key
evidence that trial was introduced from
his computer a computer that was able to
be breached when FBI agents installed a
keylogger that enabled them to get his
password and bypass his encryption
nicodemus keylogger was installed
manually but it was the first look we
would have into FBI hacking by the early
2000s the FBI was engaging in full-on
hacking operations we don't have a lot
of information about these early days of
FBI hacking most of what we do have are
some random facts like that eventually
the FBI gained control of a more
advanced keylogger that was able to be
installed remotely and that was used to
monitor an animal rights group most of
what we know comes because wired thanks
to the great reporters at Wired they did
a Freedom of Information Act request and
they were able to get a bunch of
documents about early FBI hacking
activities one of the key documents was
a 2002 memo that talked about a computer
and Internet address protocol verifier
or c path the memo accused agents of
over using the tool and they said that
it was unnecessarily raising difficult
legal questions and a risk of
suppression without any countervailing
benefit there is even less information
about this time available through the
courts even though that we knew that
these tools with the FBI now calls
network investigative techniques or nits
we're used in cases involving bomb
threats criminal fugitives and child
pornography but for the most part we
have to assume that when judges were
involved at all that they just greenlit
FBI requests to use hacking tools
but recently just in 2013 the FBI
finally hit its first roadblock Judge
Steven Smith a magistrate in Texas
denied an application for the FBI to use
an it and a case involving bank fraud
judge Smith said that the request didn't
comply with the federal rules of
Criminal Procedure and did not satisfy
the standards required by the Fourth
Amendment so I'm going to take a second
I'm going to dig into both of these
objections that judge Smith raised about
FBI hacking the procedural objections in
the constitutional rule 41 is the
Federal Rule of Criminal Procedure that
talks about searches and seizures it
governs when Officer when magistrates
can issue warrants in certain
jurisdictions for law enforcement to
conduct these activities and it has only
a few exceptions to the rule that
basically magistrates can only issue
warrants for searches that are going to
occur within their jurisdiction some of
these exceptions are examples like a
tracking warrant which means that a
search can start in one jurisdiction and
even if a criminal defendant leaves that
jurisdiction it doesn't have to stop and
be reauthorized it can continue on so
for example if they're tracking a car
they can track that car across
jurisdictions and don't have to go back
to a different magistrate the problem is
right here in the case name the FBI had
no idea where the computer wanted to
search was located and this was a huge
issue for judge Smith he basically said
that he had no jurisdiction to enter
this warrant because he didn't know if
they were going to comply with the
standards for rule 41 the FBI put
forward a lot of arguments they really
tried to convince jen smith that this
was okay and that this could occur but
judge smith through all of their
arguments out the window and denied flat
denied their application to hack into
this computer now you'd think that that
would stop the FBI but it didn't for
long and just in a few months the act
assistant attorney general issued a memo
calling for greater amendments to rule
41 to change it and allow this type of
activity to occur that memo was sent to
the Advisory Committee on criminal rules
it's this really obscure committee that
not many people know about and the
committee looked at the memo and they
were like yes we can do this and they
issued a lot of draft amendments and
those amendments did a lot of things and
amongst them they said that a judge
could now issue a warrant there would be
another exception to the limitation in
order to search a computer if the judge
did not know where that computer was
located so long as some sort of harm was
felt in the judges jurisdiction now
advocates felt that this was putting the
cart before the horse basically because
there is no statutory authority no
substantive statutory authority for the
FBI to engage in hacking operations
Congress has never considered this
they've never talked about it they've
never issued a statute saying that the
FBI can do this which is really strange
because Congress often talks about the
Electronic Communications Privacy Act or
ekta the law which governs when law
enforcement can get access to electronic
communications within equi is the
wiretap act and the wiretap act requires
for wiretaps what are called super
warrants these are warrants that have an
increased standard from other types of
surveillance they require for example
that the surveillance is limited to
certain criminal activity and they
require proof that traditional
investigative techniques have not been
successful or are too dangerous to
attempt and this was put forward because
wiretapping supposedly is more invasive
than these traditional techniques but I
would argue that hacking is even more
invasive than that it gains access to
both stored and live data it can have
unpredictable effects it can target it
can impact people who are not targets or
it can damage property it interferes
with human rights which we'll get to in
a little bit
and it's also incredibly invasive for
the people whose property might be
seized during these operations this
means that it requires even more
safeguards we think than what is
necessary for wiretapping but Congress
hasn't done that they haven't put those
safeguards into place so ekta a law that
is already by the way wildly out of date
for the purposes that it was intended to
be used for having them passed in 1986
is now being stretched its meaning is
being stretched and prodded in order to
allow it to approve activity that was
not even dreamt about when it was passed
when the federal when the Federal
Advisory Committee on Criminal Procedure
considered these rules my organization
access now along with the Electronic
Frontier Foundation the ACLU the
Electronic Privacy Information Center we
all provided testimony to the committee
we flagged that there is no statutory
authority for government hacking that it
was probably unconstitutional and that
the CFAA a federal law that the activity
was being tied to was already far far
too broadly interpreted way outside the
measures for which it was passed
unfortunately much like the honey badger
the committee did not care it went ahead
and approved the rules anyway and just
earlier this year the Supreme Court also
approved those rules this means that
they're now sitting in Congress and
unless Congress affirmatively acts to
either delay or to prevent the rules
from taking effect they're going to do
so in about six weeks this turns the
lawmaking process on its head typically
you imagine that Congress has to act for
something to happen this happens as long
as they do nothing oops
um and so it's taken about three years
but it looks like the FBI is about to
gain incredibly incredibly broad
authority by pushing through a
procedural rule without ever ever having
to talk about the substance so what
about the constitutionality the issues
the other issue that judged the judge
Smith flagged now I am going to assume
there's a lot of you but I'm going to
assume that most of you know that the
Fourth Amendment is the part of the
Constitution that talks about privacy it
is the right of the people it says to be
secure in their persons houses papers
and effects and that right shall not be
violated and no warrants shall issue but
upon probable cause supported by oath or
affirmation and and this part is really
important particularly describing the
place to be searched and the persons or
things to be seized this last part is
known as the particularity requirement
of the Fourth Amendment now judge
Smith's opinion on the constitutional
issues and on particular arity is really
important to dig into here because for a
really long time he was the only judge
that actually had issued an opinion on
the constitutionality of government
hacking Smith said that the government's
application contains little or no
explanation of how the target will be
found he keyed his decision to the fact
as I explained earlier that the FBI did
not know where the computer was located
he asked questions about if the computer
was going to be in a library in an
internet cafe or in a home where a lot
of people lived and he said there may
well be sufficient answers to these
questions but the government's
application does not supply them it's
also important to look at the
government's tools when we talk about
constitutionality the year before the
Smith case the government tried to
engage in hacking activity and it had to
reapply with a court three separate
times because its tools kept acting and
unpredictable and none planned ways its
final tool the third tool it finally got
to return to IP addresses in that case
was also flagged by the court because it
reportedly did not execute properly
that's their words the year after the
Smith case the court actually engaged in
what we call a drive by hacking
operation meaning that installed malware
not only on criminal content content
like child pornography that it's a crime
just to view but also on legitimate
websites meaning it was collecting
information about totally innocent and
Internet users now the ACLU I had said
also testified with us when we went in
front of the federal committee and they
flag some of the constitutional issues
and so I'm going to go ahead and turn to
them and their words to explain to you
some of these constitutional issues
first they said if the government
configures a website or server to
deliver malware to the computer of every
person who visits it it will likely end
up searching the computers of people who
it cannot particularly identify or
describe and as to whom it lacks
probable cause issuing a search warrant
authorizing the surreptitious delivery
of malware into computers of an unknown
number of targets raises serious legal
and policy questions moreover even if
orders for bulk installation of malware
are deemed to be proper the vast
majority of websites or servers that the
government might commandeer to deliver
malware to visitors computers will be
visited by both legitimate targets and
none targets alike so what this activity
actually looks like is what we call a
general warrant and then the time when
the Constitution is drafted general
warrants were basically the most
repugnant use of government authority in
fact one of the lawyers who was around
at that time James Otis jr. had this to
say about it I will to my dying day
opposed with all the powers and
faculties God has given me all sets
instruments of slavery on the one hand
and villainy on the other as this writ
of assistance is it appears to me the
worst instrument of arbitrary power the
most destructive of English liberty and
the fundamental principles of law that
was ever found in an English law book so
these things are really bad
and the government activity is anything
but particular it talks it would touch
upon large populations of users by
allowing them to receive the malware by
just visiting a website so it looks like
at least for now that the
constitutionality argument is on pretty
solid ground that we're pretty much in a
good place arguing that this activity is
not constitutional but it access now
we've realized and i'm guessing the rest
of you realize also that the internet is
a global technology and so when we were
trying to figure out what wasn't
happening with government hacking we
knew that we had to look abroad as well
or our analysis was just going to be
totally totally inadequate so we talked
a little bit about the United States
guys guess what countries I'm going to
next Australia actually earlier this
year it was reported that Australia had
engaged in operation in order to track
the IP addresses of every single user
visiting a website called love zone a
child pornography website it was unclear
what authority they were using to do
this but Australia actually has one of
the oldest laws allowing hacking on the
books it's authorized government hacking
since 1999 in 2014 it actually expanded
attacking Authority it can now conduct
bulk hacking operations now the idea of
bulk hacking terrifies me I don't really
know what it is but it's basically this
thing that happens for example if
companies install malware in security
updates that would be a bulk hack it
impacts everyone amongst other things
that loves own investigation actually
resulted in evidence that Australia
turned over to the FBI and was used in
the United States to indict users the
Australian Prime Minister has talked
about attacking techniques and described
them as very considerable so now i'm
going to go where you thought china and
russia were described by newsweek last
year as being the most sophisticated
cyber warfare actors apt 1a chinese
that you probably all have heard about
for a really long time has been in the
headlines recently because of the DNC
hack they've been operating since about
two thousand six or the earliest records
that we have Russia's biggest hacking
incident was in 2007 when they hacked
into the Estonian government's computers
and prevented users from being able to
access government facilities online in
2014 when Russia hosted the Olympics the
US State Department actually warned that
users should expect zero privacy in
Russia and that risk became reality
because security experts actually
demonstrated that the Russian government
likely was totally owning devices within
minutes of them being powered on so many
other countries Germany has been engaged
the B&D their intelligence agency and
hacking since about two thousand eleven
and there until there are police
department has engaged in hacking since
to our intelligence in 2009 police since
2011 the United Kingdom officially
acknowledged that it was hacking in 2015
when it released a code of conduct on
what they called equipment interference
which is doublespeak for government
hacking that document was finalized in
2016 although there are reports that
they've been hacking for much much
longer than that in 2016 just this year
Italy was found to be installing hacking
tools on mobile phones to bypass
encryption France has now passed a law
that allows them to hack into devices
and the United Arab Emirates the UAE was
found to have purchased a tool that
allowed it to hack into a human rights
activist simply because the government
did not what let like what that activist
was saying which brings me to the idea
that governments are not doing this on
their own they're actually contracting
with people who are providing them the
tools to do this a 2015 data breach from
hacking team which is really kind of the
biggest provider of these tools or has
been historically revealed that they
were selling tools to Italy Korea Turkey
mexico india and
lumbia among others one of their most
major clients was actually Egypt who is
has a terrible human rights record and
has also been documented buying hacking
tools from a lot of other companies
moreover there are international hacking
operations operation onymous which was
revealed in 2014 was an international
coordinated effort by governments to
track down criminal activity and warrior
pride is a hacking program that was
revealed in the Snowden documents that's
operated by the five eyes countries the
United States the United Kingdom
Australia New Zealand and Canada and
hacking operations are expanding and
we're going to see them all over the
world really soon we've talked about the
expansions to world 41 the United
Kingdom is also probably right at this
moment as I'm speaking talking about
their investigatory powers bill which
will formalize their ability to conduct
both hacking and bulk hacking operations
and recently Kazakhstan required users
in the country to require what it calls
national security certificates on their
devices in order to facilitate access to
private information and while hacking
team has clearly suffered a few setbacks
there are a lot of companies competing
to be the preeminent provider of hacking
tools to repressive countries and so
stepping back and looking at this global
picture we realized how woefully
inadequate domestic frameworks are to
address the real true invasions that
government hacking compose and we
realized that really what we need to do
is look at international law and try to
figure out international standard
safeguards and norms with the basis and
human rights that could protect users
against government activity so really
what are human rights human rights are
not necessarily things you can say there
are things you innately present
possessed by the virtue of being born
however there are a lot of documents
that try to set these out they cannot
provide you with human rights but they
can guarantee them they can identify
them and they can let you know
when governments can or cannot interfere
with them the Universal Declaration of
Human Rights has been around since
nineteen forty eight it's received
really broad support from governments
all over the world and is kind of the
the initial document we go to when we
talk about human rights the standards in
the UDHR have been used in other
documents like the International
Covenant on Civil and Political Rights
the American Convention on Human Rights
and the European Declaration on human
rights but before we go further why
don't we take a step back so I come from
Washington DC is there anybody else from
DC here represent so it means I have to
talk to a bunch of people who do not
understand technology at all all the
time and I have to try to explain these
really complex topics and I'm not a
technologist I'm a lawyer I'm sorry um I
always feel the need to apologize when I
say that and so I talked to our tech
team at access now and what we came up
with were these three broad categories
that we could fit most hacking
operations into and that way we don't
have to go through every single tactic
technique tool all of the different
little nitty gritty details in the ways
that governments can hack instead we
looked at what the government's were
trying to accomplish and we divided it
into messaging control causing damage
and surveillance so message in control
is basically what happens when the
government's change the messaging and
text messages or emails mess with the
domain name system to go from one
website and redirect you to another
surreptitiously or actually deface a
website to change the content on that
web site causing damage what the talin
manual would call a cyber attack is what
happens when either external or internal
damage is caused by hacking operation so
think about for example if a gun was
made to shoot at a target that it wasn't
necessarily intended to shoot at you
know that would never happen
early on that would be in the causing
damage category also in this category is
if data and databases was changed and
made to be unreliable in some way and
the final category is perhaps the best
known maybe where most hacking
operations that we know about have taken
place and that's the commission of
surveillance or intelligence gathering
this includes both directly gathering
information as well as undermining
encryption standards or protocols in
order to facilitate the easy gathering
of information now because hacking is
really really invasive all of these
activities undermine human rights and so
a little bit of human rights terminology
when something messes with human rights
we say that it interferes with that
right and hacking interferes with a lot
of Rights and I'm going to talk about
three the first is due process due
process is really important because it
basically provides the protections to
make sure that other human rights are
respected and human due process was
really messed with in a lot of ways by
government hacking first we totally get
rid of notice any idea that there is
overt notice from hacking activity is
taken away and our surveillance activity
is taken away in government hacking
furthermore hacking to damage property
without any remedy without any process
meaning it can deprive you of your
property rights it can also damage the
internet infrastructure that we all come
to rely on the Snowden documents
actually revealed that the NSA had
caused damage it had when it was trying
to monitor sir the internet in Syria it
inadvertently shut down the entire
internet um this is can we get audio you
might crash the system as I'm just it's
a dangerous thing when you hack a system
you don't actually know what's going to
happen you might crash the system as I'm
just looking at my iPad over here update
to Twitter not yet not an app that was
written by some teenager in her garage
someplace but for some users the app
crashed on launch well you figured
Twitter tested their app but for some
people it's going it wasn't working a
few weeks ago Apple issued updates for
iPads guess what if you had an iPad pro
it might have bricked it completely and
utterly and permanently disabled the
device apple certainly tested their
software update 8 that 0 i believe it
was to iOS iphones some people could no
longer make phone calls again they
tested to put it doesn't testing doesn't
always catch everything because every
computer is different different
operational characters to different apps
different usage patterns when you hack
something you are taking a risk that you
are going to damage the device so
clearly causing damage is actually a
really really huge problem here and not
necessarily the intentional damage the
damage that government set out to create
in that category but damage that is
totally unintentional it happens as a
result of the tool or technique being
deployed in a way that's not foreseen
privacy is another human right that
hacking deals with them probably the one
we're most aware of notably when we talk
about interfering with the right to
privacy what we're talking about is
protected information so that means
either public and from our private
information but it can also mean public
information if it's analyzed or put
together in a way that reveals private
details about you so if somebody goes
through my public twitter feed and puts
it into an algorithm to it that's able
to determine secret details about who I
am probably things that I don't even
know that would be protected information
and that's what we're concerned about in
the right to privacy finally the the
last major human right interfered with
by government hacking is the freedoms to
expression opinion and Association Frank
LaRue who was the United Nations
apertura and freedom of expression
explain that when a cyberattack can be
attributed to the state it clearly
constitutes a violation of its
obligation to respect the right of
freedom of opinion and expression so
then what what are the rules to
government hacking we look through all
of these international laws the court
cases and international courts and
related topics things like eminent
domain and try to see if we could pull
out some rules to the road on government
hacking to be applied internationally so
the first thing we realize is that there
needs to be a presumptive prohibition on
government hacking activity and now
before you scoff that doesn't mean it
can never happen it means that in order
for hacking for governments to justify
hacking operations they need to show
that there are safeguards in place and
that they're going to do it it respect
with respect for human rights now that's
going to be specifically pretty
difficult in some of these categories
and it might not be possible categories
like messaging control and causing
damage where the risk of harm is
especially great government hacking
might not be able to occur there might
we might just need to prohibit it
outright looking at eminent domain
looking at government propaganda and the
rules that we've come to accept with
those things that bolsters that
conclusion but when we looked at
surveillance we realized that it wasn't
so clear cut and that it might be
possible for governments to hack in
order to conduct surveillance in line
with human rights but in order for them
to do that it needs significant
safeguards the type of safeguards that
no government not the United States not
anyplace all over the world has ever put
into place these safeguards are set out
in the international principles on the
application of human rights to
communication surveillance which is a
mouthful and we just call them the
principles um because who wants to say
that so let's recap we have talked about
the fact that government hacking is
taking place we've talked about
the fact that it's probably going to
continue to take place despite the fact
that there's really a huge failure and
communicating or in talking about what
that activity should look like we've
talked about the need to apply human
rights standards to government hacking
and how to apply those standards and
that when you look at it that we need to
probably put in place a presumptive
prohibition on government hacking and
then we've said that that prohibition
might be able to be rebutted if there
are really significant safeguards in
place in order to protect users against
the government so I'm going to finish
today and talk a little bit about what
we think those safeguards look like
we've set out ten first is that we need
a law that law needs to be clearly
written publicly available and it needs
to explain exactly when government
officials will have the authority to
seek authorization to engage in hacking
when they do that when they file an
application to engage in hacking we
think that they should have to specify
what categories of information they're
seeking and that that hacking activities
should never ever ever ever ever ever be
performed with discriminatory purpose or
effect after we've got that law in place
we need to talk about standards and make
sure we're using the right ones
officials should explain why it's
necessary to use hacking up packing
operations to get information and that
they cannot access that information
through other legal means and that means
that if there's app information that
they can only get through hacking but
that other information they can get
through other activities they should
engage in those other activities for
that information and only use hacking
for limited categories an application
for government hacking should identify
what devices are being targeted it
should provide a specific time period
when the hacking will take place and it
should be designed to only return those
specific necessary categories of
information and if any extra information
is collected on accident clearly because
they never collect extra information on
purpose it should be deleted and bulk
hacking we think should be prohibited it
essentially impacts the entire internet
infrastructure and causes damage I can
be felt globally and so we feel like
bulk hacking needs to be outright
prohibited applications for government
hacking should be properly reviewed and
approved by an independent incompetent
judicial authority now judges don't
really understand necessarily what
technology does they don't often have
smartphones even a lot of them still use
old flip phones so that means judges
need to be supplied with experts that
can provide them information on the
possible ramifications of government
hacking and the risk of unintended
consequences so at a minimum they should
have access to these technical experts
we'd prefer that this happened in an
outright adversarial process but that's
just not how systems of surveillance
tend to work and importantly government
hacking should be different from other
types of surveillance in a key way and
that's a lot of surveillance is allowed
to happen in emergency situations and we
think because of the extreme risks of
government hacking there should always
be prior approval of these operations
now transparency is the hardest part and
it's probably the part that people in
favor of government hacking bristle the
most at current hacking practice our
current surveillance practice all over
the world basically says that even when
notice is required by law in different
countries that they can withhold it and
some of them do withhold it indefinitely
but it's the most important part because
of the increased risk of harm we feel
like applications eventually need to be
filed publicly although it's not
necessarily necessarily necessary for
governments to disclose the exact tools
that they're using and that notice may
be delayed so long as it's in
conjunction with human rights
protections we also think that officials
should to the extent possible and we
note that it won't always be possible
but they should monitor how their tools
are being deployed and keep a track of
the status of the tool and if it
operates in ways that are unexpected
they should report that back to the
judicial authority
private entities should never ever be
compelled to assist government's to hack
into their own products and services and
ways that undermine user security and
that could be even in cases like the
Apple example out of San Bernardino but
also cases where companies are under
request polite requests by governments
to implement certain technologies or
standards that would make hacking more
pop more easy and finally if protected
information is yielded outside the
authorization and the reason for that
collection of X the reason for that
collection should be studied and judges
should be provided with the
justification and future measures that
will be taken to prevent it from
occurring again extraterritorial
government hacking should not occur
unless it's in line with principles of
dual criminality which is a legal lees
term meaning it's illegal in both
jurisdictions not just where it starts
or not just where it ends and finally
and this is probably the most hotly
debated issue that I'll bring up because
unpatched vulnerabilities create global
risks once discovered or recede they
should be promptly disclosed to a
developer delay should be possible yes
thank you delay should be possible but
it should be in extraordinary
circumstances routine public reports of
when those delays happen need to be made
and they need to identify exactly what
justification governments are using now
none of this none of this is easy having
this conversation has not been easy um
there are those that I know who would
say that government hacking should never
occur ever in the history of the world
and in all of the future to come and
there are people who think that it
should occur with no transparency no
safeguards and no oversight at all and I
have been yelled at by both sides of
that equation and human rights but the
half human rights should not be
sacrificed at the altar of government
hacking and human rights aren't the only
equities at issue here hacking can harm
property can harm the Internet
it can harm other rights as well but if
we don't hack really dangerous people
could continue to walk free men like
Nicodemo Scarfo or the people who were
visiting love zone so we really need to
be having this conversation and often
difficult conversations tend to yield
the best results and because i believe
hacking probably isn't going away
anytime soon it's going to be important
for decades to come that we get this
conversation right and we get it right
right now so thank you very much thanks
to the organizers and if you have any
questions I'd be happy to take some of
them
there's one at top if you can scream
so the question was the globalization of
internet frameworks I believe you talked
about the ayana transition um we have
been in favor of the eye on a transition
we think it's a net positive it's going
to be a positive thing for Human Rights
there's a lot of misinformation out
there about what's going to happen
because of that we've been trying to
remedy that a little bit we have a few
blog posts up on our website we've
recently signed on to a letter happy to
point you to some resources if you're
more interested in that topic and the
wrist went down here gray gray looks
like
so the question was about trying to make
the government hacking for their damage
caused during hacking operations and we
think that might be necessary actually
not necessarily all of the time
specifically when they intend to occur
damage or when they do it negligently or
when they do it accidentally and then
use the same tool again and again um you
need to have that check to make sure
that they're monitoring how their tool
is working we actually in it so this is
comes from a paper that we just
published called a government response
or a human rights response to government
hacking and initially we tried to think
about if we could require the government
to monitor how how their tool was
impacting non targets and to try to
provide notice to non targets that they
might have been impacted by hacking
tools that maybe their computer had been
owned and realized that that just wasn't
possible but we think that there needs
to be some sort of check to have the
government staying answerable to people
that it doesn't it shouldn't be hacking
at all and there is another one over
here
sure so then the question specified the
different changes to rule 41 which I
didn't go into um there are a couple
changes about notice that aren't
relevant here but basically they say
it's an exception to the rule that says
if the government wants to hack um it
doesn't have to be in the jurisdiction
where the computer is if a they don't
know where it is and there has been some
effort to hide the location or if there
has been harm within the definition of
the Computer Fraud and Abuse Act the
CFAA and computers are located in five
or more jurisdictions sorry um so each
one of them we think is over broad the
first ones actually specifically targets
people for using VPNs it means that the
government can forum shop you if you use
the VPN do it does anybody here use a
VPN that's I expected that much um that
means that the government can go to any
court in order to get a warrant to hack
into your computer and forum shopping is
a real threat and it's not only just to
determine the location there has been a
alternative proposal to limit this
search to just getting location and then
requiring them to go to the right court
in the right jurisdiction to get the
rest of the warrant to get other
information that has been kicked out
that's not going to be in the amendment
it also is going to allow global hacking
which is something that nobody is really
clear what the standard should be but it
means that if computers are located
outside the US the government will be
able to hack into them the second change
the five or more jurisdictions there
again a few problems the first is that
the CFAA again has been interpreted way
broadly which means that there are a lot
of things that are harm within the
definition of the CFAA the change is
specifically though getting at botnets
and what it wants to do is allow the
government to be able to search the
computers of botnet victims not the
computer of the person not trying to go
up but try
to get into their computers every
technologist I've talked to and I'm more
than happy to hear from those in this
room during the rest of the conference
has been really confused about why they
need this authority that there are other
ways to take down botnets without doing
this Susan Landau Stephen Bell oven who
you saw on screen and Matt blaze have
all questioned why this is necessary and
so I tend to defer to them on their
technical expertise but they seem to
think that this isn't a good change
either um there's
so I'm not going to give legal advice um
so the question was what do you do when
the knock on the door comes from the
government asking very politely for you
to turn on over information sometimes
it's alter your service in a way
sometimes it's all different things
first of all is these non-legal requests
these like voluntarily hey do this
aren't legally binding so you can
challenge those you don't have to do it
um you if it is legally but if it's a
court request you can challenge that
we've seen people like kellett the calyx
Institute challenge gag orders challenge
court orders we've seen yahoo challenge
court orders in the FISA Court we're
seeing Microsoft challenge court orders
for data now we've seen app everybody
has seen Apple challenge the government
trying to do this so you can stand up it
is difficult we know there are people
who will help you do that and I
encourage you to reach out to those
people there are a lot of lawyers i am
happy to give names of lawyers after
this that will give legal advice but i
don't feel like it might be prudent to
do that in an audience at this size
right down front
mm-hmm great so the question is where do
you go if you're not in the US so great
question I'm access now is actually
international we have offices in
Brussels Costa Rica the Philippines
India all over the world and people who
are happy to help you there are
organizations that we work with a jury
the European digital right since
European digital rights is a group of a
lot of organizations in Europe as well
as an organization itself that can
provide help electronic frontier is
Australia it depends on your location
there are groups all over the world
working on these issues and they're
happy to provide you more information
both about what you can do in regard to
what has already happened and how to
object to things that are upcoming so
for example if any of you are from the
UK anyone yeah you should be really
really really really hard pressing to
get rid of the investigatory powers act
or postpone it because it's a bad piece
of legislation uh many women questions
anyone yes
mm-hmm now this is so the question was
what hope to marginalize people hope
what hope do marginalize people have to
get justice in a system that's kind of
set up against them is that um we really
feel like first of all there needs to be
so much more oversight put in place on
government surveillance activities and
other activities that impact users
there's a tremendous lack of oversight
where oversight tends to occur actually
is when we start to get information
about things and they like trying to
figure out how we're getting information
which is backward we think that actually
again when we say that we think that
these activities should be monitored and
reported back to a judge we think that
there should be repercussions both for
the agency that allows this to happen
but also for the individual agents if
it's a flat-out refusal to comply with
these limitations it happens way too
often this is another reason we object
to this VPN use activists journalists
there are people on victims of domestic
violence there are people who need to
protect where they are located who
should not have to reveal that and
should not have to give up legal rights
just because they don't want to reveal
to the world their location into anybody
who can sniff their Wi-Fi where they're
operating out of and that's exactly the
the government is turning that on its
head and using that as evidence of
wrongdoing and those people aren't doing
anything wrong I can take one more
question if there's one
so there are the question was how do you
deal with companies who willingly clued
with government there are documents that
actually say that companies have the
same obligations to respect human rights
as the government has and we have been
trying to figure out how to leverage
those documents against companies
there's been a lot of shareholder
advocacy pushing for companies to comply
with human rights there's an amazing
project called ranking digital rights
run by Rebecca MacKinnon out of the new
America out of New America that is
actually trying to specifically go to
companies and see how much they are
complying with human rights standards
and if this collusion is happening and
that project has really been kicking off
within the last couple years but it's
done amazing work so far and getting
responses from companies on this this
issue so I think that's it for time
thank you thank you so much I really
appreciate all of you sitting here with
me